bueno hay de todo es decir que antes
había tal vez más trabajo a nivel de
cortometrajes eso es el trabajo por
ejemplo de guapi con lo que sigue
viajando en las comunidades y
produciendo cortos con la gente de las
comunidades pero también hay películas
largometrajes ficción bueno conocemos
obviamente esa que con con tan arrugado
y así hacen también documentales
increíbles pero también presentamos una
película de un realizador de vancouver
muchísimo increíbles y se llama la
película núcleo
como
en base de las vidas verdaderas de la
gente en la parte más pobre de canadá
y los personajes que son indígenas y no
indígenas ayudaron con la escritura de
la película
mi vida es como que están actuando con
sus propias vidas y es hay algo algún
elemento mágico también de sueño lo
onírico
entonces esta película
no he visto nada igual entonces usted
dice que vamos vamos bien